LeBron the only player that's played
this meant this much in year 20 the
playoffs is Kareem and just wondered and
you know at the level that he was then
how are you able to put this together to
respond to game five of where did that
start mentally and then when when did
you start to feel that swell with your
teammates as well in the court tonight
um probably when we landed back in L.A
after game five uh you know the whole
thing in my mind was how much rest I can
get
um you know going you know from that
game four where we you know we spend a
lot of energy in that game and they had
to leave the very next morning and you
know trying to bounce back to game five
uh it was just it was tough our whole
ball Club including myself and from the
moment that we landed um here after game
five uh all I was thinking about was
just trying to sleep as much as I could
rest as much as I could make sure my
body was uh came out my treatment and my
rehab and things of that nature but
staying on my feet as much as possible
coming into tonight and
um felt pretty good when I woke up this
morning I felt excellent actually this
morning and the reason I was here so
early too but you know it was a good
bounce back for us a Big Time game for
us and uh you know we fed off our fans
once again and you know
it's great for us to be able to give
back to them like they gave us tonight
it was possible that would be great to
go a day well Brian uh over here on the
side we know the rigors of the job can
sometimes be tiring 40 plus minutes the
travel was all they alike and sometimes
your opponents May key in on that as
they view you uh how's the game of
basketball keep you young
um well I mean obviously as I get older
I play I'm playing with you much younger
guys
I think my my boys keep me young me and
my sons they keep me young so um
I mean usually before games I watch a
lot of film on the opponent
but my son Bryce actually had an AAU
team AAU game uybl game in Phoenix
tonight
so up until probably about
45 minutes on the clock I was watching
his game
and watching him going out there and
Performing and seeing him play
that kind of inspired me as well it kept
me young tonight
Taylor hey Brian
obviously you guys wanted to treat
tonight like a game seven uh and what
specific ways did you do that and how
did you instill the mentality down
through the team I was definitely a game
seven mentality Force
um you know um
I understood that we had an opportunity
to play in front of our fans we want to
try to end it tonight we came out with a
disposition uh what a what a next plate
mentality and even when we made mistakes
we we brush it off right away and move
on to the next play so I just think from
the start of the game we was just locked
in on our game plan and all the way till
uh in the final seconds of the game damn
LeBron
um when you signed with this team in
2018 you talked about moments and stuff
like that and the opportunity to have
these special moments here but all sorts
of circumstances kept a lot of those
from happening injuries covid no crowds
Etc
um was there any moment tonight
that stood out to you is like this this
is why you wanted to be a Laker
um I just wanted to be a part of a you
know a historical franchise when I
decided to come here and be able to just
change The Narrative of what the
franchise has been going through before
I got here for a few years and you know
obviously this franchise is known for
for winning championships and winning
big and playing in big games and being a
part of the postseason and the fans
coming out and having an opportunity to
to be a part of that so
um you know you know tonight is another
moment that I've always
Envision
um you know and when I became part of
his franchise and like you said because
of circumstances things of that nature
coveted and you know injuries and things
of that nature we haven't had many
policies and games with a full capacity
season
um but it's full capacity stadium so but
so far we've had three and they've been
Electric in this postseason and we hope
to continue that the next round
Ron how dominant was 80 defensively
during this series
[Music]
um I think it was 80.
I think we all know the world knows that
the basketball guys know the competition
know
that how dominant Haiti is defensively
so he was 80
um you're spectacular
LeBron Darvin said that you shared some
things with the guys after the game was
over about the next level what did you
say to them and why was it important for
you to share that with that team
because we got a young ball club with
not much experience in the postseason so
just try to get my knowledge about you
know what I've been through and uh what
they could
expect you know so as hard as this
series felt and as hard as this series
was it gets even harder when you move a
level up so we was able to conquer Level
one and now we move level level two and
it gets harder and harder so
um
you know they understood that and you
know they'd be ready for it last two
we'll go Ramona and then we'll end with
Rachel Ron you you talked about just the
connection with the crowd in this game
do you feel a deeper connection with a
crowd in La this year just as Dan
mentioned that you haven't you didn't
get to do that in 2020 and 21 and all
that I Know Jack Nicholson was here for
the first time since the since uh the
last year's season opener do you feel
that building as these playoffs go on
and you get to play in front of this
home crowd
um
I mean I feel blessed to be able to play
the game
anytime I put on a uniform and to be
able to put on a Laker uniform and play
if it's a historical franchise it's
always an honor
um
the connection I think you got to ask
the fan you gotta ask the Laker fans the
connection is between me and them you
know I feel welcome
I'm happy to go out there and perform
and showcase what I'm still able to do
20 years in the game and uh
hopefully I'll just add to more memories
that they've had for so long so many
great players and so many great teams
and hopefully I can be part of some of
those memories
last question Abram what was your first
thought when you saw the schedule for
the next round being every other night
and what challenge is that
um
well it's definitely going to be a
challenge but both teams have to go
through it
you know it's us in either Sacramento or
or Golden State we're going to be on
both on the same schedule
the plus is that it's not a four-hour
flight like we were just taking to go to
Memphis and losing two hours you know
during the process so use he was losing
six hours just going back there right
off jump so um you know we stay in the
same time zone we stay in the same state
it's an hour flight to each Place less
of a sack a little bit more if it's to
the Bay
so that definitely helps I know I know
you guys are happy about that as well
yeah for sure especially BT going to
Wine Country no matter where we go so
yeah yeah he already he wrote them nose
down already he tapping in already so
it's all good man NBA is in a good place
all right appreciate it thanks